les lacs la forêt la campagne rarement
les montréalais auront rêver autant de
nature en ces temps de pandémie
ils sont nombreux comme isabelle dorais
à avoir décidé de changer de vie avec le
confinement cdn aquarium la gelée j'ai
vu tout d'un coup d'envoi l'aquarium
telle image qu'elle a maintenant de son
appartement situé au 9e étage d'une tour
à condos du centre ville pendant deux
mois
allez sur son balcon a été sa seule
sortie d'être confiné dans ces quelques
mètres carrés dans cet appartement leur
et puis ne pas avoir accès à la verdure
de pas y aller parce que étant à risque
mais je me suis confiné encore plus que
les autres quand j'ai vu la maison saint
sauveur j'ai faites de l'air du verre la
verdure d'oxygène je pense que c'est ça
qui fait vite changer madistin elle a
payé sa future maison - 2 325 mille
dollars
une aubaine par rapport au marché
montréalais d'autant qu'elle procédera
en plus un immense terrain isabelle
n'est pas la seule à avoir eu l'appel
des laurentides en sang un engouement
pour des notes territoire l'eau tout ce
qui est sur la rive nord et les
laurentides
les agents immobiliers de la région par
d'une ruée vers le nord
seulement au cours des dix premiers
jours de juin ils ont vendu 462
propriété alors que l'an dernier qui
était déjà une bonne année
318 vente avait été enregistré une
hausse de 45% après il faut prendre en
considération c'est qu'on n'a pas nos
acheteurs étrangers
donc c'est 100 % des québécois qui
achètent une autre territoire
actuellement parmi leurs achats il y a
des chalets bien sûr mais aussi beaucoup
de résidences principales
plusieurs nous disent ganci jamais
arrivé nos pandémie ça ne tente pas de
vivre ça en milieu plus urbain ii il ya
l'assouplissement des entreprises à
vouloir encourager les gens travaillent
et de la propriété de la maison donc le
travail à la maison va devenir
les mains un peu plus à la mode c'est si
on peut dire isabelle qui enseigne en
adaptation scolaire à laval a fait du
télétravail ce printemps même si elle
n'a pas aimé
elle admet qu'il y aura des avantages si
ça devait se poursuivre si l'on devait
commencer comme ça l'année scolaire bah
c'est sûr que le jeu reste très bien
placé et puis je vais être dans un bel
environnement et je pense que ça va
peut-être aider aussi à m'organiser pour
bien travailler même si la population
montréalaise continue d'augmenter
surtout en raison de l'immigration n'en
demeure pas mois et que chaque année
rappelle gilles ouellette vingt mille
résidents quitte lille pour aller vivre
ailleurs
et cet exode selon lui face amplifie je
pense que des villages comme sainte
adèle sainte-agathe vont connaître un
regain de popularité saint donat qui est
un organe egli gérard donne ces endroits
là c'est tout des villages abandonnés ou
des villes qui sont d'après moi sous
développés les beaux endroits
magnifiques avec de beaux paysages du
sud les cantons-de-l'est séduisent eux
aussi très excité c'est une un nouveau
chapitre de ma vie qui commence
tania lice en rêvait depuis longtemps
d'y déménager et la corrida accélérer
son projet parce que j phi jabbes parce
que mon fai savent en appartement puis
le pauvre et riche effectif du quad
milieu d'acheter ma maison puis mona
lippi femmes au rêve plutôt après 13 ans
dans ahuntsic
elle vient donc d'acheter cette maison
centenaire aalesund elle l'a payé 270
mille dollars après avoir vendu son
grand con du montréalais 500 mille
dollars
j'adore mon quartier ahuntsic sa
quartier génial c'est la campagne en
ville mais il ya toujours du bruit peu
d'intimité suis rendu là depuis le 1er
mai au nord remarqué une augmentation
des ventes d'ast hors de la région de
montréal on parle à peu près du double
daf rares provenant de cette région
l'eau ici aussi bien des nouveaux
résidents envisage le télétravail
l'internet haute vitesse environ 68 %
des transactions qu'on fait
c'est des gens qui vont venir s'établir
ici en permanence
et là où l'air pur devient l'air marin
les montréalais font aussi parler d'eux
dans le bas saint laurent et en gaspésie
plusieurs agents immobiliers les appelle
les 5 1 4 et ils sont plus nombreux à
appeler ce printemps souvent davantage
pour s'informer que pour acheter
mais on peine encore qu'avec la combine
bien des citadins veulent prendre le
large
[Musique]